basically what went wrong is that the
Member States and the European
Commission did not follow their legal
obligations the fact is not that we
didn't know that the problems that we
did in fact based on the knowledge that
we had both at European Commission level
and in several member states the main
reason was economic interest millions of
jobs and Carla street
it was inefficient how the system worked
many people knew about discrepancies
between the lab measurements and the
on-road testing but no one really was
curious to effectively see what really
happens it was a lot of course of pity
because otherwise we should have
improved the system much earlier we need
European approach and more effectiveness
in control the old test was in a lab
during 20 minutes on their very
artificial circumstances on the road it
suddenly emitted much more dangerous
pollutants than than during the cell
cycle so the new test cycle has been
developed now the second point is
oversight European oversight if we have
a precise law we have to guarantee that
the law is applied in the member states
at the same level in equal manner this
is very important so that we do not have
those kind of 28 interpretation of law
if member states will accept this we
will have always a system which will not
work in detail
in the end what matters is that there is
much stronger European oversight and I
trust the Commission it's the guardian
of the treaty as long as the Commission
is convinced that it should follow the
right path which means that air quality
is the main objective and not the
defence of car industry the message to
the public is that we learn the lessons
from the past and we will now do our
homework introduce the Audi testing so
this scandal will never happen a second
time
[Music]
you
[Music]